andrew schultz has revolutionized the  comedy game twice and here's how andrew  started stand-up while in college in  california but returned to new york city  after graduation despite becoming a  staple of the new york scene and finding  tv success on shows like guy code all  the networks passed on giving him his  own comedy special so in september of  2017 andrew released his own comedy  special on youtube called 441 that now  has over two and a half million views  and the album 551 was number one on  itunes and comedy billboard charts  andrew schultz is also dominating the  podcasting game with brilliant idiots  that he co-host with charlemagne the god  and flagrant with his co-host akash  singh mark gagnon and alex media in 2022  after refusing to edit out offensive  jokes andrew bought back his infamous  comedy special from a big streaming  platform and ended up making three times  his investment so for anyone looking to  become a famous comedian watch and learn  how